[Musik]
das ist natürlich ein steiniger weg über
die kirchgasse mit einer vitrine so ab
weil ich habe dann einfach da viel kraft
aber alle zusammen rolle gehört zusammen
waren als bischof das ist extrem wichtig
kinder in der berger hat just
gemeindepräsident von alpinen jost sagt
sein kleines tor steht kurz vor dem tod
nun wollen es die bewohner um jeden
preis retten
wegzug aus dem tal rosenschild und elmar
an tomaten ziehen nach alpinen so schön
- oder sagen große houten schild hat
zusammen mit seiner freundin ein haus
gekauft jetzt werd ich saß oft reine
kann erklärt der zeuge buffon der
gemeindeordnung wonach sie vor elf
jahren auch wenn er kurz spitze
abgesegnet werden genauso sauer weil du
baust du aber da würden der verträge
halten schild und elmar antraten haben
von der gemeinde alpinen für die haus je
25000 franken erhalten
dafür müssen die beiden mindestens zehn
jahre im dorf bleiben und 200000 franken
investieren
die gebürtige philippinen lebt seit acht
jahren im wallis
ich habe diese pillen gefunden
[Musik]
die beiden kennen sich seit einem jahr
die zukunft in alpinen kann beginnen
[Musik]
im touristenort alpinen im oberwallis
250 leute wohnen hier in den letzten
jahren wurden es immer weniger
einst gab es hier eine post zwei banken
eine schule und junge leute jetzt ist
das dorf am aussterben
mehr als die hälfte der einwohner ist
über 60 jahre alt geld hätte die
gemeinde genug
doch es fehlt der nachwuchs
[Musik]
gemeindepräsident beat jost will das
ändern
hilfe von außen erwartet der linke
politiker nicht mehr das parkgebiet cave
auch dokumente schweiz selbst im
bundesrat sicher komfort motto wo gehe
ich nehme mit overweight
das ist das drama und werde im kanton
selber zu dass man vom morgen bis aber
dahinter ist darüber noch nicht beendet
oder die lina dokumente bestätigen
jetzt sagt die gemeinde könne sich nur
selber vor dem untergang retten
die zeit der durch könige und der
politischen grabenkämpfe sei vorbei nun
müssten sich alle gemeinsam für sie
überleben engagieren und ideen
einbringen
ein solcher vorschlag aus dem volk
brachte das dorf im november 2017
beinahe zum kollaps junge bewohner
hatten die idee finanzielle anreize zu
schaffen damit junge und familien in
alpen bleiben oder gar hierher ziehen
geld für ein monat darüber wurde
abgestimmt
der vorschlag löste ein weltweites
medienecho aus und einen rummel den man
hier an einer uhr versammlung noch nie
erlebt hatte der gemeindepräsident
fürchtete um die unabhängigkeit der
zukunftsweisenden abstimmung trotz
kritik und spektakel sagten sie alwine
deutlich ja zu der vorlage
doch das durch kam nicht zur ruhe im
allgemeinen getöse gegen unter dass das
geld der gemeinde an enge bedingungen
geknüpft ist für die sogenannte wohnbau
und familienförderung kommen längst
nicht alle in frage
wer über 45 ist kriegt kein geld
ausländer brauchen eine
niederlassungsbewilligung c trotzdem
trafen 12.000 anfragen aus aller welt
ein
das sind der ware billiger als wenn man
sich wie job mit referenz mit sieg
nichts mit foto mit cds frisches bild
von der familie war seit dieser familie
riesige familie entschädigung 4
und der ist baby fahrradtour noah ja der
unglaubliche sache griechischer
professor südamerika oder war in
südamerika vor schick machen oder und
ich gebe ja noch ein thema die alpinen
serien idealo.de um die albertina vor
sechs wochen ja das ist kann man das
institut mache sie garantiert dass sie
mit professor oder du hast den scorpions
sind sehr schwachen trend analyse
stellmach uns in der familie libyen
fliegen
das interessant
noch heute kämen leute von weither ins
dorf in der hoffnung bleiben zu können
jost sagt es komme vielleicht die
reinste tag wo man auch dieses fenster
öffnen müsse um nicht auszusterben
[Musik]
elmar an tomaten und rose haudenschild
sind seit kurzem besitzer dieses hauses
darin steckt ihr des staates und der
zustupf der gemeinde zwei wohnungen im
haus vermieten sie den mittleren stock
haben sie bezogen
[Musik]
eine woche oder zwei wochen aber nachher
ist nach gar nicht so aus wie eine bombe
die beiden unterstützen die wohnbau und
familienförderung der gemeinde auch
andere sollen davon profitieren können
sagen sie ich finde das eine komische
ich finde das eigentlich mit liebe zum
detail wenn man wirklich hat am dorf
heißt und haben alles probiert so dass
das durchschnitt unser guide oder also
hier freuen wäre sie ja so oft wie sie
die das glück der beiden ist auch das
glück von alpinen die gemeinde hat mit
ihnen zwei einwohnern mehr
es ist mitte herbst alpinen hat zum
ersten durchschneidet aufgerufen an 27
ständen verkaufen einheimische
gemeindepräsident jost ist zufrieden der
markt ist ein voller erfolg
die idee dazu entstand in einer eigenen
spur gruppe und kommt von der
30-jährigen mühle steffen
mitmachen zahl blieb und so das ist
natürlich sucht der gäste versetzte zu
diesem zeitpunkt ist die neue wohnbau
und familienförderung schon fast ein
jahr in kraft
gemeindepräsident jost der transparenz
und offenheit hoch halt muss deswegen
nach wie vor kritik einstecken muss
wenige die stört matthäus sind äußerlich
gelassen die offizielle mehrheit im dorf
unterstützt die argumentation der
gemeinde
das konzept wird
[Musik]
jonathan das ganz andere familien
entzweit diese frage werden wunder wahr
und was hält junge in einem dorf da
selten so beliebt ist wie an diesem tag
über den hermann hat auswärts studiert
und ist nach alpinen zurückgekehrt er
schätzt die ruhe hier hermann gehört zu
den mit initianten der wohnbauförderung
und möchte vielleicht selber einmal
davon profitieren
mit hiesigen kräuter angebaut auf
terrassen rund ums dorf versucht er sich
ein standbein aufzubauen
die zeitaufwendige arbeit gewinnbringend
zu betreiben sei allerdings schwierig
schluss mb der initiative der luxury
gehen oder ein piano lied wo welche
schlussendlich schwierigkeiten finden
das ist eigentlich das wichtigste an
seinem heck fallen der hochfelder super
job finden wird so schwierig viele alben
finden nur auswärts arbeit
die jobs sind unten im tal der
arbeitsweg vor allem im winter je nach
dem gestell ich fischfabrik wahlberg in
rom mit warmwasser vom lötschberg wird
hier täglich berichtet seit sechs jahren
arbeitet hier elmar anthamatten ihre
arbeit beginnt frühmorgens um 6
weil so früh noch kein bus fährt bringt
sie freund rutsche täglich mit dem auto
zur arbeit so umständlich der weg und so
frost sich die arbeitstemperatur für
einen job nimmt das elm einkauf
ich habe gar nicht problem ikb ikb
mit gelten
nicht alle aber von ist doch technik so
verbleibt damit es mit dem arbeitsweg
zum neuen wohnort eigenen passt lernt
sie nun auto fahren
zurück in alpinen rusche haudenschild
hat im dorfladen ware bestellt die
gemeinde hat den laden vor drei jahren
gekauft
er drohte zu verschwinden weil er sich
nicht rentierte das defizit von mehreren
zehntausend franken jährlich deckt nun
die gemeinde das könne und wolle man
sich leisten das sei sehr wichtig sagte
gemeindepräsident für sein restaurant
auf der regelmäßigen dorfladen ein das
sei praktisch wenn auch etwas tötet in
alpinen gibt es mehrere beizen die mit
seinem alten dorfkerne gehört dass
mutter hannelore joggen hat sich mit
ihrem kleinen restaurant kurz war die
stube eine nische geschaffen auf dem
teller landet was im eigenen garten
wächst oder aus der region kommt pro tag
gibt es ein mensch dank mama hat der
gelernte koch einen job in haltern
wer hier nicht fix ist und das macht
noch einmal sagen jetzt bin ich hier in
stunden
das kann ingolstadt oder so britischen
bbc dass sein fach wirklich nicht
statisch und monaten mit rose
haudenschild mutter ist ursprünglich aus
einem nachbardorf von alpinen als er
klein war lebte sie mit ihm im unterland
vor 15 jahren zog es sie wieder in die
berge
die erste drehorte stickel herrsche also
wo ist das normal märchen ist nicht
sicher aber ich habe immer an mich auch
die stimmgerät bei mir gesagt haben
araber und hinter weiß ich dass das
richtige
ich bin extrem gar wird ich mache das
einfach gar die lippe hohe mobilität und
die freiheit und auch nicht nur mehr
freiheit und kreis eine twitter
[Musik]
es ist montagabend im november und
amazon geht zum ersten mal in den
alpinen damen turnverein
[Musik]
der daumen zum verein ist einer von
sechs vereinen im dorf
aktuell zählt 22 mitglieder herzlich
willkommen wir waren nie ein großes
theater wenn wir freuen uns eben über
neu zu können wir machen heute ein
spezielles aufwärmen und zwar gibt es
verschiedene posten diese person die den
posten leicht joggend hat macht zwei
runden also wirklich leicht machen wenn
sie zwei runden gemacht hat sagt immer
diese person jetzt den posten wechseln
gut dann geht's los
jung und alt sind in diesem verein
gemischt
[Musik]
es wird für immer anzulassen vorerst bei
diesem einen besuch in ton verein
bleiben
seit ich passe es gerade nicht so gut
sagt sie
feiertagen alpinen die bestrebungen das
dorf zu beleben tragen früchte alpinen
erhält den oberwalliser heimatschutz
preis der gemeindepräsident will nicht
den eindruck erwecken das sei alles auf
seinem mist gewachsen zeigt mit ihrem
projekt stellvertretend für viele
wollenberg modellhaft auf wie man der
problematik der aussterbenden durfte
entgegenwirken kann
medic von der jury beispielhaft und
privat wir gratulieren
zur feier des tages spendiert die
gemeinde burggen keller ein großzügiges
nachts und der heimatschutz erklärt was
mit beispielhaft gemeint ist das
sperrengeschoss privaten unter strom
setzen und seine freundin das ich denke
der relativ stark bevölkert ich medizin
und das war das alles andere als ein
geheimnis gemacht
es ist winzer geworden frische houten
schild und selma anzuraten wohnen seit
drei monaten in ihrem neuen haus jetzt
die auch hier ist natürlich noch nichts
verlangen was na ja ich würde jetzt eine
matratze im schlafzimmer die wird die
werden gerade zeige was man so braucht
zum schlafen ja wunderbar zufrieden ja
wohl schön gar freitag zehn jahre müssen
die beiden in albernen bleiben sollten
sie vorher wegziehen gibt der zustupf
ans haus von insgesamt 50.000 franken
zurück an die gemeinde mit all das
konnte ich nicht sagen will du hier auf
biegen und brechen blieben bisher salon
smartphone und in zukunft länger
für die gemeinde war es ein
erfolgreiches jahr
20 personen sind zugezogen ein teil
davon dank des förderprogramms fürs jahr
2009 10 hat alpinen das wohnbau budget
aufgestockt drei neue gesuche sind
hängig der gemeindepräsident beat jost
wagt zu träumen
hier im bürgerhaus wo einst die schule
drin war ein großer traum mal vermisst
landes alarm und abläufe und so vermisst
darunter das ist es riesig riesig
ich sage ja dass ich immer realistischer
versuchen das unmögliche apple wie mo
yan exhibition große wäsche großer grün
realistisch sein und das unmögliche
wagen mit dieser parole der 68er
bewegung million mit seinem dorf in die
zukunft aufbrechen
gelungen ist in kurzer zeit schon vieles
was unmöglich schien
[Musik]